look I'll help you I'll take your poster
outside for you no I'd like you to keep
it here for when the police arrive but I
would love it from the police arrived
cuz that's actually evidence so I'd like
to keep it ah Austin Texas a city of
great coffee great food great
conversation and people who want to
vandalize our property and see us die
he's just your local transgender juice
barista who calls for acts of violence
in a spare time what kinds of acts like
publicly posting our specific location
with calls to visit us slash our tires
and teach us lessons insuring that will
never make ourselves vulnerable again
how do we know that he/she Z meant
business because he/she Z said so while
recruiting the same friends who helped
him to face the robbery least ask you at
UT hilly that's a crime too oh well
civility is great but you plot violence
it's time to confront
[Music]
take it
never make no no you remember me at all
steven crowder at all no not familiar
this is you threatening to slash my
tires here where this slashed my tires
and actually funny enough also also the
robert e lee statue seems you help
defend we're trying to work let me ask
you what do you think it's okay to
threaten slash someone's tires I didn't
take it predictable Z the first instinct
is always denial so might need to do
this oh man lucky for us we had a
bristol board how about you check this
out here don't feel for me
what will we this cop yeah yeah I'm a
conservative was a difference of opinion
from you and I've never threatened
actions of violence I've never friend
the slash ring when you need to get out
we're gonna call the police
you know what less let's call the police
officers because a matter of fact we
actually have that no no actually I
would like to speak with the police
we're about to file a report very soon
okay you should do that this is a part
of being a man is owning up to the
actions here when you threaten violence
against someone when you're threatened
violence against some way part of being
a man is taking ownership of your
actions taking responsibility but I
don't believe we're gonna be here
because you're a dishonest human being
you said you didn't even post this and
acted like you didn't know me I think
you're a liar let me ask you this could
you just say hey you're sorry
take this down could you take this down
could you take it down to their other
pits not going anywhere
well there you go you to submit it to
doing it so you think it's so plan
threaten someone and slash they're tired
I didn't do it further than a Joe are
your tires okay so that make it you it's
a crime it's a crime to threaten that
you understand that right okay it's a
crime you take it now could you take it
down yeah it's a crime you take it down
or just just say hey listen I don't
really want to call actions to violence
that people history
part of beat come on we want to play the
part part of being a man is owning up to
the actions been admitting what you did
they call the police well good I think
they should call the police
I think it's called place we should file
a report I would like to before filing
report offer you the chance to take it
down and just stop with the threats of
violence you stop with the threats you
take it down all right and but everybody
knows this person's being abused first
off I would never threaten anyone here
with violence I hate violence certainly
for political opinions well we actually
had to change my mind which is a segment
we do where we sit down we actually
Danielle here who's running for City
Council a transgender person sit down
for 40 minutes and talk at that time
threatening to slash our tires and
someone who works at UT was asking their
car to be firebomb the time for
discussing is over it's time to renounce
the acts of violence coming from people
who you employ so I can't speak to this
I'm on the clock in this right now again
I you can read can't you
what's in it and I've listened to you
look I'll help you I'll take your poster
outside for you no I'd like you to keep
it here for when the police arrive but I
would love it for when the police arrive
because that's actually evidence so I'd
like to keep it for where did you put
the board um one of your friends nicely
yanked it out of my hands and he has it
outside gosh so they got they got
slightly thank you a little Yankee a
little game a little Yankee walk out
with your GoPros and you're pretty
cameras oh that's right I guess no right
to film only when the super racist
fascist police arrived to save them from
the super racist fascist comedian it
turns out and so we are filming this too
soon I don't want you to she's
complaining that you know the right to
film doesn't again these people don't
understand single party consent laws No
doesn't that strike you as odd they
attempt to claim that we were committing
a crime yet none of them not one
employee year manager began filming
because we want as much sunlight as
possible the left operates exclusively
in the dark so it turns out the police
were actually super helpful nice and had
a better grasp on the laws and our
favorite baristas they were so great
they even went out of their way to refer
to Z by shims biological gender
where they just posted on her wall about
Facebook yes all this person who works
there and she works in here
I guess they saw right past that
newfound 5 o'clock shadow bigots oh well
it was at this point that we use their
police call to file our very own police
report yeah you can we have copies it's
gonna go to our detectives and then our
detectives will carry it from there you
can call 3-1-1 given that case number
it's gonna be the report that I'm gonna
be writing well thanks for being so
helpful if you send that email I will
get you everything any questions you
guys have thank you so I hope you know
Sam I'm coming from I do not want to
make your lives harder you're not at all
but we're your wives our kids hurt you
know I'm sure you get it now the point
where we peacefully leave go home sit on
our footage and wait for leftists to do
what leftists do lie luckily we didn't
have to wait long at all for this
Facebook post only none of that is true
I don't live in Austin we're not
expecting I haven't spent all of my
money in a rudimentary Google search
would show you I've been married happily
for six years
so why the lies about everything why
don't you want something so you like
your secret's safe with us
in any case thanks for the plug
it feels good to be loved but just
remember kids we have eyes everywhere
and we encourage all of you to be
filming as early and often as possible
and if you act out violently or
malevolently be prepared to deal with
the consequences because I will find you
I will confront you and I will shame you
[Music]
[Applause]
like Samantha bee of course not because
you actually made it to this end card
you are a miracle of the Internet I
would say subscribe or hit the
notification button but I don't really
know what that means on YouTube you
might not get notified anyway but you
can join up at laterthe greater calm
slash mug club that's monk with this
wonderful hand etched mug and you get to
watch not only clips but the full
one-hour Daily Show every single day
that was redundant because I said daily
but every single day but we're gonna
keep it anyway because we shoot these
end cards a whole lot in one afternoon
we're scraping the bottom of the barrel
is this one